wir hatten ja keinen so guten start ich
würde sagen wir fangen wir mal von vorn
haben ich bin lutz van dorst wer sind
sie ich bin gas wieder
[Musik]
hallo holly ich habe die ganze nacht
kein auge zugetan
denn heute werde ich ihn treffen
[Musik]
sie können mich schon ja schon mal
gesehen ist der mattscheibe kohlroulade
hat nur anna winkler
hallo
[Musik]
ein
auch heute nicht so gut
weitere nato künast habe ich mich nicht
mehr so zu einem mann hingezogen für die
von städtischer wirklich geil drauf aber
das war jetzt eine art obama t shirt hat
es auch großartig läuft es zwischen
ihnen nicht wäre peer steinbrück ein
geeigneter vizekanzler und peer
steinbrück das ist wurde er doch schnell
vizekanzler
wir hatten ja keinen so guten start ich
würde sagen wir fangen wir mal von vorn
haben ich bin dort werden sie dass weder
gelesen etwas auch wer das auch in
waltz' lob oder der tod für mich keine
wirklich völlig unbeleckt er überlegt
ich bin so werner winkler super süß weil
er so wunderbar auch mit herz weise club
ich werde kurz rein gegriffen wie fühlt
sich das an
dass werner winkler jetzt so schnell ich
verließ man also schnell mit ihnen auf
augenhöhe ist ich freue mich darüber
dass wir hier und da hinten werner
winkler widernatürliche kritik
zum beispiel in der google suchleiste
erscheint hinter trittin als erstes
prostituierte hat man schon den
vorschlag namensvorschlag fdp hat dann
lieber aus situierter einen werner
winkler
es gibt nur ein rot wir wollen ja dass
sie gewinnt
doch alles klar
[Musik]
so was wie eine mischung aus
vor allem fehlten erst mal die worte ich
suche greifen der veranda smile und wer
und damit zurück ins studio
werner
[Applaus]